the Joe Rogan experience what do you
think about combat jujitsu Eddie's new
invention man I think is a way for
people to step up to reality and
understand and some guys make a decision
to know what I might be able to go and
do mm-hmm but that's a real world yeah
if you fight somebody that's exactly
what's gonna happen right and making
people more aware of okay my jujitsu for
Jiu Jitsu sport only this is not gonna
work there well for this kind of issue
sheets I have not to be aware more of my
real fight yeah and I think it will help
more the evolution of that sport of Jiu
Jitsu to transition MMA for people don't
know what combat jujitsu is Eddie Bravo
invented a way where you do Jiu Jitsu
with slaps on the ground and you you
would think it's just oh it's just slap
but no a palm strike really I mean you
really can hit someone very very hard
with your palms I mean I can do that
with my hand on a table and it doesn't
hurt my hand at all but if I did that
with my knuckles it would really hurt so
they're there they can smack the [ __ ]
out of each other we stood in that after
we trained jujitsu still call and
Portuguese
top idea second slap each other after
the training no shirts yes and we used
to train like that in Brazil
oh really it has to be ready again we
have no tournaments right and me after
the train let's see and we stand in
front of each other and open hands and
there we go slap each other make sure I
don't get slapped on the face but on the
end of training have marks mmm all of
your body and you still shake your
brother's hand they love you but y'all
over mess
[Applause]